[Alkış]
tekrar merhabalar nasıl gidiyor bence
sunumlar çok iyi ben kendim çok beğendim
Umarım şimdi sizi Siber güvenlikle
sıkmam ne demek ya teddiye işinde gelip
burada Siber güvenlik Anlatacağım değil
mi biraz Umarım ilginç olacak hadi
başlayalım
Siber Güvenlik
hiç eklenmediğine inanan var mı ya da
aman Sibel günlükten Bana ne diyen var
mı aranızda
Hiç mi ilgilenmiyorsunuz hocam sosyal
medyanız var mı
kimliğiniz var mı
biliyorsunuz değil mi kimlikler sızdı ve
biri herhangi birisini okuyayım
Siber güvenlik bir şekilde hepimizin
ilgisini çeken ya da hepimizin bir
şekilde bağlayan bir şey Peki hocam siz
hariç Sibel Güvenlik ürünü olmayan var
mı hepimize bir şekilde var değil mi
antivirüs olsun ya da ne bileyim
telefonunuz muhakkak vardı değil mi
güvercininde güvercin kullanmıyorsunuz
Tamam bir şekilde
ürünler koyup kendimizi güvene almaya
çalışıyoruz biliyorsunuz değil mi aşağı
yukarı yıllık maliyeti 450 milyar dolar
dakikada bu birkaç milyon dolara mavi
oluyor maliyeti Siber güvenliğin bize bu
hackerların verdiği zarar E madem durum
bu
hepiniz kendinizi bir yerde buldunuz
burada Hayır ben bu tabloyum diyen var
mı Yok bir şekilde sanal dünyada
bahsetti İşte Hocam bize az öyle tanışın
Azrail
hocam kızmayın Azra çok iyi bir işçi
sizden verdiğiniz önce insan felsefesini
alıyor ve evlenmek üzere hazırım Hiç
sorun yok Ne yapıyor öyle vaktinde
kesinlikle istatisten çalmadan
bilgisayardan gelinlik arıyor bakın öğle
saatinde
tamam Normal kendi ararken Google'a
giriyor ya da bin falan birden yanlış
bir siteye tıklıyor ve o tıklanma ile
hacklenebiliyor bu hepinizin başına
gelebilir değil mi öyle oluyor Hani
isterseniz sıfıra bira inerim hiç sorun
değil dedim ya 10 kitap var blaket
dünyanın en büyük Sibel Konferansı dahil
olmak üzere 43 ülkede seminer verdim
yani şu an teknik detaya inmeden basitçe
anlatmak istiyorum
bu Azra'nın başına gelebiliyorsa Bizim
de başımıza gelebilir ama
bu Normal bildiğimiz partilerde verirler
ya resmen diyoruz sen Türkçesini
bilmiyorum ama takıyorsun o partiye
davetli olduğunuza dair
o de eminim ismini bir kere duymuşsunuz
En azından
doğum günü davetiyesi
hackerların bir tanesi bunu bir şekilde
öğreniyor
böyle resmen bir tane yaptırıyor gidip
Paris hiltonunun 3200 dolarlık pastasını
çalıyor ve evsizlere dağıtıyor
şimdi dikkat Yani tabii ki Helal olsun
değil mi Ama o siz olsaydınız O sizin
doğum günün pastamız olsaydı
ben gülüyorum ki zaten sizinle
paylaşıyorum Buyurun Bu da gazete küpürü
Paris Hilton'un başına geliyor Bu sadece
Paris hiltona mı
dedim ya 43 ülkeye dolaştım Doğu tümör
diye bir ülke var bileniniz var mı oraya
gittim En azından bir kişi biliyor şöyle
söyleyeyim Birleşmiş Milletler arabası
ile aldılar beni korumalı falan fistan
birleşmiş milletlere senden öğrenmeye
gittim Her gittiğimde işte güvenlikten
geçmek zorundaydım Ya arkadaşım dedim
ben Türk'üm bana da mı Hani bize de bir
menü var ya Cem Yılmaz'ın bana da mı
beni dedim sana dedi dediler
öyle mi sosyal mühendisliklerinin şöyle
gördüğünüz gibi bizitirden kendime
bildiğiniz birleşmiş milletlerin giriş
faturasını aldım nasıl mı geçtim dedim
sizin ola nerede şurası kapıyı vurdum
geçtim bağıra çağıra Siz benim Türklük
çok işe yarıyor Siz benim kim olduğumu
biliyor musunuz dedim
adamlar baktı 150 şanslar var
olmuyor mu burada Garibim trafik memuru
durduruyor Siz benim kim olduğumu
biliyor musunuz
ya bana bu kartı verirseniz ya da
10 dakika sonra bu kartonlarda
detaylarını kitapta anlattım kitapta
getirmiştim ama şimdi 15 dakikam var ya
kısa kısa özet özet diyorum bunu iyi
oluyor
nasıl oluyor Hani Sayın cumhurbaşkanının
tabiriyle kimler hacklenmedi kimler hani
yapayım da evet nazik şu da bu kadar
tutacağım
Bu kadar yeter bence
şimdi kimler mi eklenmedi bir şirket
söyleyeyim bana fpa'ya göre iki türlü
şirket vardır bir
eklendiğini bilenler iki bilmeyenler
yani her canı ölümü tadacaktır var ya
Her canlı hacklenmeyi bir şekilde
tadacaktır Ben eklenmedim mi Tabii ki
eklendim Ee ne yapacağız
bakalım ne yazıyor orada siz ne
durumdasınız
şimdi
Ben iyiyim ya da ben kötüyüm diyebilecek
olan kimse var mı Biliyorum burada
bilişimden birkaç arkadaşım da var var
mı
ben Ben de olsam ben de kaldırmam açık
söyleyeyim Hani
YouTube'da var gece biz de evindesiniz
konferansta 2-3000 kişi var yine çıkıp
anlattım senaryo gereği hacklendim işte
anlatmaya çalıştım işte Ben doktordan
Özkaya şunu yaptım bunu yaptım ben bile
ekranı verirken oradan bir el kaldırdı E
bu senaryo dedi Evet dedim seni arıyor
yani Tabii ki bir gün önce çalışıldı
yoksa sahneyi falan nasıl ekleyeceğim
böyle dedim ya
YouTube'da var 5 saniye
5 saniye sonra 2005-15 yılında oldu bu
bir USB taktık Bir bilgisayarla 5 saniye
sonra bilgisayar benimdi YouTube'da
izleyebilirsiniz 5 saniye ya da burada
canlı da yapabilirim ama vakit yok fazla
Tamam şimdi o zaman yine sohbete devam
edelim
hocam sizden bahsettiniz kim ünlü olmak
istiyor Halil hocam da bahsetti sizi en
iyi kim tanır
Anneniz mi
en yakın arkadaşınız mı
yoksa kim var
size soruyorum arkada dostunuz mu
yoksa telefonunuz mu
telefonunuz değil mi bu ranza dediğimiz
saldırılar nasıl oluyor Hani ben şimdi
hocam şifrenizi ver desem bana verir
misiniz binlerce takipçiniz var
Instagram'da beğenmişsiniz değil mi
Ee
para bana para verdi seminer vermezsiniz
Peki telefonunuza bir şekilde
hakim olup telefondaki bilgileri alıp
sızdırma ile tehdit etsem ne yaparsanız
Tabii ki verirsiniz e durumda Aynen öyle
olmuyor mu Ee ne yapacağız yapacağımız
şey basit Aslında Sibel güvenliği
ciddiye alacağız Nasıl olacak o iş
şimdi
bir doktora gittiğinizde
işte Doktor bey doktor hanım Her neyse
beni tedavi edin Tabii ki diyorsun da
Doktorunuz size bakıp size ne olduğunu
mu anlamasını bekliyorsunuz yoksa işte
Doktor bey doktor hanım işte öksürüyorum
öksürürken sağ ayağımdaki baş
parmağındaki Kırım sonra dönüyor o sola
dönüşüyle canım acıyor gibi detaylar mı
veriyorsunuz Tabii ki ne kadar çok Detay
verirseniz Doktor da onları alıp işte
yaptığı tehditlerle size bir teşhiste
bulunacak doğru mudur
peki
bilgisayarınız telefonunuz Hocam size
soruyorum hemen telefonunuz var değil mi
Evet siz elinizde gördüm zaten kaç tane
aplikasyon yüklü telefonunuza biliyor
musunuz
10-15 tane Ben iddia ediyorum Daha fazla
belki bilgisayar olmayan var mı öyle
diyeyim hocam sizin ne var değil mi
güvercinlerin yanında Peki bir
insanınıza neler var biliyor musunuz
değil mi bilmiyorum şöyle bir soru
soruyorum hayatında hiç renkli ürün
kullanmayan var mı
Windows satın almıyorsunuz geçip işte
kırığını indiriyorsunuz ya da ne bileyim
işte önce Hanım dizilerini internetten
bedava izlemeyen var mı ya da benim
kitaplara internetten indirmeyiniz var
mı Hepimiz bir şekilde yaptık değil mi
Dürüst olalım
E peki
bir soru daha bir dakika ben anlatmaya
mı geldim Soru sormaya mı geldim Tamam
arkadan buraya
bedava bu dünyada ne var
Öz anneniz bile severken En azından bir
saygı sevgi bekliyor
doğru mudur Arda dedi ya tanrı tanrı
bile Ya gidin bana tapanın diyor
birbirinize iyi davran diyor yoksa
yakarım sizi diyor Bütün dinlerde öyle
Bu herifler size bedava niye bir şey
versin
hacklenmemek için eklemeyi öğrenmek
anlatabilirim değil mi bir daha iki kere
düşünün
başka bir tarafta dünyanın en iyi
teknolojisi
adını Siz koyun
bir tarafta da insan hatası Sizce bu
yarışı kim kazanır
dedim ya az önce gördünüz beklenen bir
sürü şirket bir sürü banka bankada da
silso olarak sende
genel
Siber Güvenlikten sorumludur şu anda
eksilttim yine neyse berberlik şirkette
dünyanın en büyük şirketlerinden bir
tanesi yine aynı şey yapıyorum
öyle şeyler görüyorum ki
Ne yapmamız lazım Hele Bunu size nasıl
anlatacağım değil mi plaket değil ki
bunları birkaç kurala indir dedim bir
her gördüğünüze inanmayacaksınız
Serap da değil mi Bunun ismi
Serap mıydı karıştırdım Serap işte çölde
kendinizi birden şeyli zannediyorsunuz
değil mi böyle
bu adam ne güzel böyle poz vereniniz var
mı aranızda
var değil mi
biliyorsunuz değil mi
ya da yine ünlü olmak istiyoruz
İnstagramda milyonlarımız olmasını
istiyoruz paylaşmak istiyoruz ama Her
gördüğünüz gerçek mi Facebook'ta
Instagram'da
sosyal medyada
değil mi Hani gerçekte göründüğünüz
İnstagramda göründüğünüz
başka ikinci Kural paylaşmak Tabii ki
önemli Halil hocam anlattı ne güzel
hepinize gaza geldik ayağa kalktı falan
ama ne kadar
Hocam dedi hoca gibi oluyorum yoksa
nasıl hem üzüldüğümüz yerler arkadaşım
sen ilk aldığın kredi kartını
paylaşmazsın ya Twitter'dan
ya da Yaşasın Amerikalı oldum Bilmem ne
oldum Buyurun ilk pasaportum
ya da bu bakın tarihe bakın Teyzemin
oğlu izleyecektir muhakkak şu anda
Maldivler'de Facebook'ta hava atıyor Ne
güzel değil mi malzemelere gidiyor
bakın şurada yakınlaştıracağım tarih 27
Mayıs şurada birkaç gün oldu Ne güzel
paylaşmış Ama dikkat etmenizi istediğim
çok önemli şeyler var Pasaport numarası
bakın hacklenirsiniz telefon numaranızı
değiştirirsiniz
hacklenirseniz İnstagram adresinizi
Hani bir şey paylaşırken çok basit
özellikle indirmek istedim bir şey
paylaşırken
düşünmek lazım
paylaşmak ama ne kadar en basiti kızacak
bana izlerken bunu
3 1 güvenlik açığı varsa muhakkak
kullanılacaktır yani o sınavın kısası
microsoftada çalıştığım yıllarca Hatta
20 işçisi ödül var
5 milyar dolar
ya da bir sürü şey bir insan ürünü bir
şey yapıldıysa muhakkak açık
bulunacaktır bu alçak eklenecektir Tabii
ki burada istatistikler var sadece
bilmenizi istediğim bir istatistikler
her sene artıyor
virüs bile yazdırabiliyorsunuz Artık
bırakın Ödev falan yaptırmayı
virüs yaz bana diyor ve yazıyor
hastanede uzanmışken hocamın anlattığı
gibi birden kendinizi uzayda
görüyorsunuz
bir sürprizim var şimdi kitap getirmeyi
unuttum dedim Ama herkes bir ayağa
kalkıp sandalyesi altına baksın sürpriz
sürpriz sandalyenizin altında bir
bakarsanız sandalyenizin altından
bir şey yok mu
Ya arkadaşım ben size Sabahtan beri ne
anlatıyorum her dördünüze inanmayın
değil mi
insanlar güvenmeleri gerektiğini
öğrenemiyorlar ve sürekli Niye
öğreniyorsunuz ki bana biraz daha
zamanım olsaydı bunu yaptım işte
atıyorum Bu akşam nusret'te
Yonca hanımla yemek
alabilir miyim diyorum veriyor
güvenlik gerekçesiyle sonra sahnede
yapıyorum bunu yine YouTube'da
izleyebilirsiniz canlı direkt sigorta
şirketi mi arıyorum bana çarpan araba
işte Erdal Özkaya ehliyet numarası bu
falan ya bir dakika bir dakika niye
güveniyorsun ki
her gördüğünüze inanmayın ve güvenmeyin
başka
insan ürünü olan her şey eklenebilir
bunu anladık değil mi Arda deneyiz
anlattı bizde Yani insan ürünü bile hep
bende bakın Adem Havva
bir insan
cennetteler hepimiz yaşıyoruz cennete
gitmek için her Ben bak hoca da gittim
Vatikan'a da gittim Bir buğdaya da
gittim alamadım
tamam mı Tamam bu bizim de yok mu gerçi
ama adam da hava figürü var nedir adamda
Havva İşte cennetteler biz niye
yaşıyoruz cennete gitmek için yani
inananlar ya da hepiniz hikayeyi
biliyorsunuz cennetteler İşte buna göre
şeytan bana göre de sosyal mühendis
geldi yani
elma ağacına baksana ne yaptı Ona
inandırdı değil mi bizde de öyle olmuyor
mu internette işte bir bakıyorsunuz
ucuza şeyler var Bir bakıyorsunuz bir
şekilde sürekli kandırılmaya yönelik
bizim ilk anne babamız hacklendiyse Eğer
değil mi o tıklama isteği bizde yok mu
elleme ıslak boyalı
ellemeyeniniz var mı bir kere bile Hocam
siz bile yapmışsınızdır değil mi ya da
Dokunma
Aramızda Kalsın Ama kimseye söyleme
değil
6 sene şüpheye düşürürseniz birinci
kuralı hatırlayın Birinci kural neydi
her gördüğünüze inanmayın Madem öyle
Buyurun direkt
klonlayabiliyorsunuz ve kendinizi başka
bir insan gibi gösterebiliyorsunuz
bir dolara iPhone olduğunuzu nasıl
inanıyorsunuz ki ya da
buyurun bir defa iPhone'a inanıyorsunuz
oynanmış sonuçta 4 tekeri olmasa 4 ayağı
var
görüyorsunuz değil mi yani her
gördüğünüze inanmayın derken BMW logosu
var orada
Bu arada Afrika'da hiç akrabası olmayan
var mı
Hayır olmayanlar mı o kadar da Türkçem
var Canım hiç mi yok
Estağfurullah hocam siz laf atın Ben
sabaha kadar alırım 35 saniyem kaldı
Star Fatma kalmam ben Peki bu iğneli
almayınız var mı İşte ben Afrika'daki
kuzeniniz falan gelmeden bir gün önce
vardı Aa dedim kullanayım Hepimizin bir
şekilde Afrika'da akrabalar var değil mi
prensler falan kusura bakma
bu kadar
unutmayın
herkes Siz dahil bu işin parçasısınız ve
süper güvenlik önce başta anlatıldığı
gibi sizinle başlar
Evet şimdi süremin bir 30 saniye üstüne
gideceğim Size laf yetiştireceğim diyor
Hocam
olması lazım E nasıl olacak bu bakın
Londra metrosu bir tarafta
bilet basıyorsunuz bir tarafta kocaman
açık Ben Türk'üm Sizce nereden gittim
yok Sadece fotoğraf çektim ya da ister
inan ister inanmayın çok çok büyük bir
bankanın yani çatı değil hocam Allah
sizinkinde değil
şifre ya da çok çok büyük bir
şirketin laptopu ve şifre üstünde
bakalım uçakta beyefendi çalışıyor müdür
onunla gurur duyuyordur nereden bilsin
ki Erdal'ın fotoğrafını çekti zumayınca
Aslında gizli bir belge yazdığında
göreceksiniz
ya da yandaki teyze çok sevdi beni sağ
olsun o kadar Güvendik ki cüzdanını
bakın kartım o kart Benim şurada kart
var
benim bu da cüzdanı hızlı hızlı çektim
abi olmasın diye ya güvenin de nereye
kadar unutmayın deriz
aptallık için maalesef yama bulunmuyor
lütfen telefonlarınızı Bilgisayarınızı
ve bitirmeden önce
bir 30 saniye üstüne gittim biliyorum
ama size birkaç soru sormak istiyorum
sizin için en önemli şey nedir ayağa
kaldırmayacağım sizi kendiniz
olduğunuzda tesadüfen bakın Siber
güvenlik işte öyle bir şey her şeye
dokunabilmektir ve kesinlikle hiçbir
konuda konuşacağını bilmiyordum ama bir
şekilde hepsine tutturdum değil mi
kimdir aileniz mi
yoksa
arkadaşlarınız mı
yoksa Paranız mı
kimliğiniz mi Bunların hepsini parça
parça paylaşamadılarsanız yoksa
Neyi o güvenilirliğiniz mi Düşünsenize
Ben doktorlarla Özkaya bana Güven'in
sonra ben size e-mail atıyorum başkası
diye O atıyorum bana güvendiğin şeyi
paylaşıyorum yoksa kariyeriniz mi
arkadaşlar erkeği kapak olmuş mu vardır
hocam
Bu da kapak olsun falan espri yapayım
bari ya bunu hiç Dünyanın her yerinde Bu
espriyi yapamıyorum Bu da size kapak
olsun
ne verirsiniz için önemli olan nedir
unutmayın hepimiz
Son soru
bilgisayarınız telefonunuz modeminiz ne
kadar güvende Çok teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]
Beğendiyseniz beğen Erdal Özkaya
beğenmediyseniz adım Ömer Çolakoğlu